what a movie going be like in the age of
coven 19 we were curious to find out
whether moviegoers would ever feel
comfortable again going to a movie
theater and sitting in a darkened place
surrounded by strangers so he went to
Texas which eased restrictions on
theaters and other retail establishments
to see whether consumers would be
willing to take some risk for the escape
that going to the movies has always
offered so in Texas we have two of the
theaters we have in Texas are our two
that are the biggest theaters in Texas
so prior to the cove at nineteen reality
that we live in our theater chain is the
24th largest in the United States and
that's measured by screens and we were
accustomed to anywhere between five
point two and five point four million
people a year coming through Earth
coming through our theaters to enjoy the
luxury really the luxury recliners that
we have and the great popcorn that we
have and and you know we're in the
entertainment business and it's just get
away from life for a while forget about
deadlines forget about the pressures of
school and the pressures of everything
else that's what we were accustomed to
prior to March as we were shutting down
because various parts of the country
started to shut down at different times
by the middle of March we were operating
in a very different way already we get
started checkerboarding our seats
meaning you weren't gonna sit side by
side with somebody who didn't know there
was gonna be space between you space
behind you we weren't wearing masks back
then but we were starting to practice
social distancing even inside of our
theaters it was a very different way of
operating and attendance frankly had
dropped down by the middle of March to
about five percent of what we were
accustomed to we were not gonna mandate
that employees needed to come back to
the office so I said we need to start
making phone calls now and we got to
figure out do the employees feel safe
coming back to work but if our employees
had said we don't feel comfortable
coming back we would not have opened so
we chose three theaters
we called the the employees that have
worked at those three theaters and I
would tell you we had about 80 to 85%
yes I want to come back to work
which is cool but but candidly the way
we were operating when we shut down in
March our employees vote great and and
so that's why we decided to open we are
not going to see obviously an immediate
return to normal levels of attendance
movie theaters anywhere in the country
right now and of course in many parts of
the country it's going to be a long time
before we see any any opening of any
theater doors in some parts of the
country it's going to become more
feasible to open movie theaters earlier
because clearly the the virus is not as
intense as it is in places like large
metropolitan areas New York City being
the obvious and most extreme example
however that said I think there is going
to be a level of caution demonstrated by
the movie-going public when they
consider whether or not they actually
want to go back into the theater
environment for different titles we've
been doing research on exactly this
issue for the last several weeks and
we've seen that of movie goers at the
moment 48% of moviegoers are actually
saying that rather than go to the movie
theaters they see themselves in the
future renting and purchasing movies and
that's not just now and in the next few
months that's going forward they're
saying they're going to do that rather
than go back to the movie theaters full
stop the movie industry the exhibition
industry has really been struggling over
the last two decades theatrical
attendance has dropped even as the
number of screens nationwide have grown
more than 10 percent over the last two
decades to some 40,000 screens even
though revenue has managed to increase
in fact it's doubled over that time the
exhibitors have managed to accomplish
that in large part through increased
pricing now that's going to be something
hard for exhibitors to maintain
especially when so many kill people are
now out of work and the social
distancing has clearly made a huge
difference in our country
the models that were put in place for
Kobe 19 early on did not contemplate
social distancing and they predicted far
worse experiences and death rates than
we've experienced after social
distancing those numbers have come
dramatically down and now they're
rebuilding all those models we still
need all the health experts and health
authorities to pull all that data
together and have a definitive model but
the data I'm looking at in our area in
Texas and in San Antonio we haven't had
a new york-style outbreak or a
chicago-style outbreak so again I'm
looking at it from a data perspective I
suppose we're not gonna get caught up in
all the attention that we're getting the
most important thing that we have to do
is just execute on what it is that we do
every single day right create that safe
environment show people it can be done
and if if after all is said and done we
are a leader in terms of showing people
the way I'm happy for the industry
what the movie theater business looks
like going forward is really hard to pin
down right now anybody who gives you a
direct prescriptive answer to that
question is frankly either delusional or
trying to sell you something nobody
knows and that's that's the challenge
that everybody is trying to get their
heads around right now whether they're
small family operated outfits knowledge
chains studios it's hugely important to
the whole industry the physical kind of
remnants of social distancing are going
to be present in movie theaters for a
long time
you